antes de que les muestre la mecánica de
lo que es el rotacional de un campo
vectorial en realidad vamos a tratar de
cachar un poco de intuición así que he
dibujado un campo vectorial de dos
dimensiones esto lo podemos extrapolar a
tres pero esto es solo para cachar
intuición así que veamos aquí están los
ejes x
muy bien y cuando james relativamente
bajo nuestra magnitud del vector del
campo vectorial se hace un poquito más
largo a medida que vamos aumentando en y
ok ahora esto no depende de dx correcto
así que sólo aumenta en la dirección y
ok
digamos entonces que en la dirección x
se permanece la la magnitud de los
vectores dados por el campo vectorial
así que para una llegada la magnitud del
vector puede permanecer igual no
entonces lo que estoy diciendo es que
nuestro campo vectorial puede ser no sé
qué cuadrada por el vector y así que la
magnitud de la dirección x es sólo una
de tu valor correcto ahora mientras tus
valores se van haciendo más y más
grandes en la dirección
tu dirección x es la que se va
incrementando verdad es decir si aumenta
y aumenta el vector pero en la dirección
x sólo depende de hierro así que vamos a
pintar a estos vectores más grande para
continuar la idea
solo son puntos de muestra de nuestro
campo vectorial pero esto es suficiente
para obtener la intuición necesaria
ahora déjame hacer una pregunta si yo
fuera digamos a poner que este campo
vectorial es un campo de velocidad de un
fluido a lo mejor no sé estamos viendo
un río quizás ahora si tomamos una
ramita o una varita algo y lo colocamos
en este fluido déjenme pintar aquí de
una vez la ramita
aunque no vamos a utilizar esta
herramienta digamos que pongo esta
ramita aquí es una rama bastante
graciosa pero bueno es suficiente con
esta verdad que le va a pasar la ramita
bueno este punto de abajo en la ramita
el agua la empuja hacia la derecha muy
bien así que pero en la parte de arriba
el agua también lo está empujando a la
derecha pero con una velocidad más
rápida verdad ahora la parte de la de
arriba se va a ver empujada más rápido
que la parte de abajo así que qué es lo
que va a ocurrir la ramita va a rotar
verdad después de no ser cierto tiempo
la rama se va a ver algo así la parte de
abajo se mueve poco pero la parte de
arriba si cambia radicalmente con
respecto a la parte de abajo y quizás
después de un poco de tiempo se ve
todavía más así
así que puedes ver que como los vectores
aumentan en su aumentar en la dirección
perpendicular a la dirección de
movimiento
esto es todo hace que la rama pueda ir
rotando verdad ahora la magnitud de los
vectores aumenta y estos aumentan a
medida que vamos aumentando nuestra
magnitud de verdad y cuando esto ocurre
el flujo está moviéndose en cierta
dirección pero está yendo a una magnitud
diferente que cualquier que hace que
cualquier objeto pueda rotar si la
derivada parcial de este campo vectorial
respecto allí está aumentando o
reduciendo sí sí sólo está cambiando
esto significa que mientras aumentan o
disminuimos la magnitud del componente x
de nuestros vectores también cambia
nuestros vectores ok y tienes
velocidades distintas mientras que si
algo se mueve en x va a estar siendo
rotado verdad así que podríamos verlo
como si esto tuviera un una torsión neta
verdad en algún objeto que se sienta
sobre el agua en este punto la última
puede ser déjenme déjenme dibujar otro
vector
otro campo vectorial la última puede ser
si yo tengo una situación parecida a la
que voy a pintar en unos momentos
digamos que tuviera esta situación donde
quizá aquí abajo es así con esta
magnitud luego quizás hace esto muy bien
se va disminuyendo pero eventualmente a
lo mejor hasta cambia de dirección
verdad así que puedes imaginar que acá
arriba se está yendo a la izquierda con
una magnitud bastante grande así que si
ponemos nuestra ramita aquí entonces no
sólo no se va a mover a la derecha sino
que este lado de arriba se empuja hacia
la izquierda y el de abajo se empuja
hacia la derecha y puedes ver que hay
una torsión neta que hace que esto esté
rotando verdad de momento nos preocupa
más la magnitud del vector cambiante no
en su dirección de movimiento como en el
ejemplo de la divergencia nos preocupa
cuál es la magnitud del campo vectorial
mientras nos movemos en dirección
perpendicular del movimiento así que que
aprendimos a partir del de cuando
hacíamos el producto punto y el producto
cruz de dos vectores bueno el producto
cruz nos dice cómo multiplicar dos
vectores para obtener una dirección
perpendicular
a esos dos mientras que el producto
punto nos dice que tan separados están
el uno del otro verdad así que
esencialmente lo que el rotacional mide
es el efecto del campo vectorial o puede
adivinar qué tanto se digamos se riza el
campo vectorial alrededor de un punto
verdad podemos poner una ramita y qué le
pasaría que le pasaría bueno si hay un
poco de rotacional pues entonces gira
ahora si el rotacional es negativo gira
en una dirección contraria verdad ahora
lo que nos importa es este sentido es
decir sólo nos va a importar si va a
favor o en contra de las manecillas del
reloj y espero que ya todo esto empieza
a encajar verdad vamos a borrar todo
esto hasta ahorita hemos estado
trabajando con el operador
del triangulito invertido pero bueno a
pesar de que en realidad no no tiene
ningún sentido cuando lo escribo así uno
puede entenderlo como un vector operador
verdad como ya lo hemos trabajado en
otros vídeos si sabes la derivada
parcial de algo en la dirección y más la
derivada parcial respecto de ella en la
dirección j
aunque y bueno podemos agregar una
tercera dimensión verdad la derivada
parcial de c está en la dirección k
cuando aplicamos esto justo al escalar o
al campo escalar o campo vectorial pues
entonces tenemos ya sea el gradiente la
divergencia ya hemos visto varias cosas
verdad por ejemplo cuando tomamos el
producto punto de este operador con con
el campo vectorial entonces tenemos la
divergencia de nuestro campo vectorial y
bueno esto ya debería ser más intuitivo
y claro pero bueno si no podríamos
revisar nuestros vídeos acerca de de la
divergencia ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es no un producto punto porque este
producto punto lo que nos dice es que
tantos
y difiere en estos dos vectores verdad
de hecho si te pones a pensarlo más
detenidamente todo lo que es una
derivada o una derivada parcial en este
caso es solo la razón de cambio la
derivada parcial en la dirección x es
cuando estamos hablando de cuánto cambia
este campo vectorial en esa dirección
verdad o estaremos hablando a lo mejor
de la dirección y cuánto cambia en esa
dirección y bueno así es como cobra
sentido la divergencia porque recordemos
que si este es un vector dado por
nuestra nuestro campo vectorial en la
dirección x pues entonces los vectores
aumentan y si tomamos un punto de un
pequeño punto pues este vamos a tener
que el campo vectorial sale más de lo
que entra y eso hace sentido de que
hablemos de una divergencia positiva
verdad sin embargo ya no quiero
confundirte mucho esta es la intuición
que ya hemos tenido en otros vídeos
sobre la razón de cambio asociado a la
divergencia
pero ahora lo que nos importa es la
razón de cambio respecto a las
direcciones perpendiculares así que el
rotacional es como puedes adivinar será
el producto cruz el producto cruz de
nuestro operador del triangulito y el
campo vectorial y si esto fuera donde tu
intuición te llevó y qué es lo que
adivinaste pues por supuesto estás en lo
correcto este es el rotacional de un
campo vectorial y es y es una medida de
qué tanto está rotando el campo el campo
vectorial o que si imaginas un objeto te
dice que tanto está rotando debido a la
acción de esta torsión neta que ejerce
el campo porque en diferentes puntos el
objeto puede tener una magnitud
diferente del campo en la misma
dirección verdad sin embargo no quiero
confundirte mucho espero que el ejemplo
de un poquito más de sentido sin embargo
creo que ya llevo más de nueve minutos
así que en el próximo vídeo vamos a
hacer el cómputo del rotacional de
alguna función vectorial
a intentar dar un dibujo de lo que esto
representa nos vemos en el próximo vídeo